what is going on everybody welcome to
the
13th financial charting tutorial where
we left off we're making a pretty nice
looking candlestick chart
this was it we've got the open well
we've got the open and closed on our
candlestick and we've got
uh volume data here so if you guys are
familiar with
candlestick charting you'll notice
probably immediately that
we didn't unless you were just like too
enamored with my colors
you'll notice that we're missing
something right we've got this line here
right that's going through we're missing
the shadow of the open high low close
basically so we're missing
the high and the low on this so really
this candlestick chart is only showing
like half the data right we're only
showing two out of the four
uh data sets so we definitely need to
fix
that and there's a couple of different
things that we can do
one we could we can specify the color
here
um but natively built into finance dot p
y
um i looked at their file it's literally
hard coded
that this line is black so so we have a
couple of different
options uh for us one is we could just
change the background color
of like this chart here to white so the
black would show up
but that's pretty lame because we'd have
to move off the darked out chart
and as we all know the darked out charts
really essential to making money and
showing everyone that we're a badass
part of the reason that the darked out
charts are for
badasses is because the noobs simply
can't do it because the
chart won't work but luckily for you
guys i'm gonna be here to teach you the
way
of the badass just kidding but not
really
anyway what we're gonna have to do to do
this is we're gonna edit the
uh core finance dot py file
and then within that the um the
candlestick
function now if you don't know what any
of that means that's okay i'm gonna hold
your hand through the entire process if
you don't know what the heck you're
doing just take it slow and copy
everything that i do
um but really this kind of uh
method will help you in the future as
well like if there is a function that
either
one you don't understand how it works or
two
you just like it's not doing what you
want to do like what i did when i first
saw this was like oh i wonder
if there's like a parameter for us to
fill in for a shadow so i looked at the
function
and no like it's literally hard coded as
a as a k which
denotes black and uh so then i was like
well okay well we'll just edit it in
so that's what we did and that's what
i'm going to show you guys how to do
so to do that we're going to close out
of here and
what you want to do is go to my computer
right you know so you got or not my
computer but you know your computer so
you
know where your disks are and um
wherever python is installed for you in
my case it's in
c by yours might be in another drive
like i've got a bunch of other drives
here with operating systems and stuff so
anyway mine it's c for prime mostly guys
it's in c so let's pop into c
then you're gonna bop over to python 27
then you should have a capital lib
i don't know how many i've probably gone
into this file like
hundreds and hundreds of times i still
get these two mixed up i'm like
which one do i click but it's always the
one that's proper right
so anyway capital lib and then down here
let's see where's my plot live am i just
blind or what oh no wait no we got a
site packages
and then matplotlib and then now you're
in matplotlib
so now we want to do is scroll down till
we get to finance
here it is now you'll notice that
there's a white one
and there's these two black ones now the
white one
is the raw file that's what we want to
do now the black one is a compiled
python file so
when we edit this it will go to the
compiled finance so you only need to
edit the one white one
so hit edit so now we're editing the
finance dot py
file awesome so this basically has all
of the finance.py stuff and as you'll
see
actually very interestingly finance py
does have a fetch
historical yahoo data it's also
got um it's there's like some files in
here too
and some kinds of interesting stuff if
you're interested in financial plotting
it'll behoove you to just kind of scroll
through this and see
what they're doing it's also got the
second version of candlestick which i
don't use i'm not sure what the point of
it is um
but yeah there's a whole bunch of stuff
and they even have like volume overlay
that's pretty interesting
we might end up using volume overlay
actually
it's kind of a waste so you don't have
to have volume on a separate chart
right like we've got volume on a second
subplot what you can do is overlay the
volume on top of your current chart
but part of the problem with that is
sometimes it literally will lay over
your financial data which i don't really
like but
there's probably a min and max setting
that we can all figure out and then we
can just like
include that in the tutorial um that's
like a real basic function the one i use
is pretty intense so
um maybe i could learn something from
their function um
anyway what we're looking for is
candlestick so just do like a control f
right and you'll get uh this little
search thing and just type in
candlestick
make sure it takes you to the regular
candlestick not candlestick 2.
so immediately when i look at this i see
okay we've got
these parameters that will either be
defined or are defined right like these
are definable and these are the default
parameters right so um
so we're not going to touch this yet but
if you scroll down here
what we're looking for is if you had no
idea where
we're looking for shadow like that's the
first thing i look for was shadow
that's not here but the only thing that
is here that sort of see lines
and we're appending some sort of v line
which i can only assume means vertical
line
so that lead well should lead you here
and then you should see that color is k
which is black for uh
for anybody that doesn't know what k is
and um
so then you know you should be like oh
well that's our problem so what if we
just did
white w for white and we just kind of
move this over and where is
my other one let's see i think this is
it yeah
so now that we've changed that let's run
this and see if we got white
sure enough you should probably see it
immediately that it's white and if we
zoom in
oh yeah yeah it's definitely white so
now we have our data back
but i'm not quite happy yet because one
we just hard coded it just like they did
i'm actually surprised that they didn't
give a parameter for it or
do what i'm going to show you guys but
that's just the way it is
but this isn't very good for a couple of
reasons one
is it just looks ugly two it looks ugly
and three if you zoom out it kind of
like distorts it a little bit like
lightens everything up so
and it looks ugly so that's not good so
what we want to do
is we're done with this edit our finance
file a little bit more
and for that i'm going to continue on in
the next video
as always thanks for watching thank you
for your support your subscriptions
and until next time